Alex, can I ask you what you do exactly?
Sorry, if you have already told me.
I work for this communication company where I'm positioned as a foreign correspondent.
One of my colleagues told me the other day...
...that recent surveys indicate that there is an increasing number of youngsters in Korea who wish to do service jobs.
But what's interesting on the opposite side of that...
...is that almost one third of parents want their kids to work government jobs.
They also see becoming a CEO, Chief Executive Officer...
...or professional businessman, professor, or medical career will promise a good life.
Parents say those jobs are stable and will make some good money too.
But I hope parents let their children choose what they want to be...
...and help their children find what they are really good at.
You are right.
The best job is one that you find yourself enjoying, and being good at.
I want to move on to talk about these new jobs.
My friend told me a list of these new occupations that I've never heard of.
Let's see if that applies to you, too.
Have you heard about a job called a tour conductor?
What about a food stylist?
A lotto designer?
A jumpmaster?
I can imagine what they are, but I have never heard about or seen one.
But those jobs certainly sound interesting!
If I am given a chance to become one of those new occupations,...
...I'd like to become a food stylist.
I really love food, so I even love to arrange food for special occasions like a big party.
I would be very happy if people eat the delicious food decorated and arranged by me.
Isn't it a great idea?